our planet has seen this before it's ice
has already melted water levels have
risen ocean currents have already
stopped now everything is coming full
circle and we should be concerned if all
those events were to happen again today
you wouldn't recognize the earth you're
living in this is what if and here's
what would happen if the Gulf Stream
shut down ocean currents dictate the
Earth's climate they push hot equatorial
waters towards the poles and return cold
polar waters to the equator in the
northern hemisphere
it's the Gulf Stream getting the job
done moving water at roughly 2 meters
per second the Gulf Stream is one of the
largest and fastest currents in the
ocean it carries warm sea water all the
way from the Gulf of Mexico to the
eastern coastlines of the US and
Newfoundland then across the Atlantic
Ocean where it splits into crossing to
northern Europe and recirculating off
West Africa the Gulf Stream is part of
the global ocean conveyor belt so what
does ice have to do with all this
currents circulating through the oceans
don't just appear out of nowhere they're
created out of differences in water
density warm water has a lower density
and rises to the surface cold water has
a higher density and therefore it sinks
to the bottom but there's one more thing
that determines the density of water the
amount of salt in it and that's where
the ice caps enter the game polar ice is
composed of fresh water as it melts it
adds more fresh water into the sea
making the water in the North Atlantic
less dense at some point it won't be
able to sink anymore the global ocean
conveyor belt will stop circulating this
would be the end of the Gulf Stream and
the beginning of something else
new ice age yeah you heard it right we
may be heating up the planet year by
year but climate isn't that simple the
Gulf Stream is a warm current it's what
makes winters on the west coast of
Europe so mild it also keeps winter
temperatures warmer and summer
temperatures cooler on Florida's east
coast what would happen if this warmth
bearing current was cut off well it
would stop bringing warm waters to those
areas Western Europe would be plunged
into a deep freeze and so would North
America ice storms were rampant through
Spain France Portugal in the UK London
among other cities would be covered in
snow for weeks the east coast of the US
would have a different problem rising
water levels normally sea levels on the
US Coast are lower compared to those on
the coasts of Europe that's because the
Gulf Stream is warmer when it gets to
Europe take the Gulf Stream out of the
equation and the water would push back
toward the u.s. that would disrupt
agriculture in those areas drowning the
economies that rely on growing and
distributing crops and while the East
Coast of America and Western Europe get
chilly in their local ice age
temperatures in the rest of the world
would keep rising climate change would
trigger fires tsunamis and hurricanes
all at the same time that would be a
different world nothing the earth hasn't
seen before except that this time
civilization would be disrupted and be
left to deal with the change in climate
when the ocean currents decide to take a
break what if one day our planet became
so hot that the oceans ran away from it
that's a story for another what if
you